the fun part of the movie was going to
be a heist movie but at the heart of the
movie was going to be in every man's
story about losing the affection of a
their child and and and so here we have
a this loser but who is in every man
likeable enough person of course in Paul
Rudd but that's where we started with
that you had to sort of figure out a
language by which you could actually
shoot this and have we had all sorts of
scale as a the kind of thing we were
really up against how do you make this
little guy look little feel little you
know in in this world and you know I
know Jake had done tons of research and
development on on how actually to shoot
it and it it became a little
counterintuitive that you couldn't use
our typical power angles to shoot him if
you use those you know the the ones
below that make them look heroic the net
result was you would ruin the scale
effect so we had a lot to figure out it
actually had this weird knock on effect
where if you shot him from below look at
looking up it made it look like an
incredible rear-projection experience in
the 50s it really looked like a guy who
is like running behind with the car
behind him and all the rest of it so so
yeah we made sure that we always shot
down on them we we boomed the camera up
and always shut down and we tried to
frame him so you would see head to toe
all the time and I think that that
always helps to sort of show you know
his diminished scale we also like over
the course of production got better I
think at not being afraid to just pull
the camera back a little bit and see
less of him because frankly he is
ant-man so smaller smaller is better
yeah I also think that it well before we
started production on ant man we saw
guardians of the galaxy and I just went
into you know shocked because I said
this is never going to be as big as
guardians of the galaxy and what are we
going to do how is it going to look
because we were working front instead of
galaxies we were working in bedrooms and
bathrooms and and it was
what do you do to make something that's
so calm and a place that we all know
look look exciting and be a place where
adventure can happen and so we all had a
dialogue about well how the sets would
be built how the camera would be staged
that certain there be certain rules the
camera moved and also what and i think
is very clever that Jake said you know
this guy moves so fast we should just
shoot it even though we're working will
eventually be working with
motion-control photography let's shoot
it as though it's handheld and he zips
out of the frame and we can barely
follow him and so you see some of that
stuff where he first falls on the floor
of the bathtub and the gun goes over
through the crack down in the ravers
room that they the camera misses them
and finds them again and there were all
those things that we would do to kind of
feel like we were actually photographing
a real event and not a smoothly
choreographed special-effects movie we
ended up sort of having our own little
terminology and the in the in
post-production that we we called a one
particular thing the gift that keeps
giving and that's going to the wide of
the real world and with him as a tiny
ant because you know if you if you just
save that like for the punches you know
punch line kind of stuff it always
worked and it was always fun so you'd be
with him and then all of a sudden Wham
you see you know the set with the little
guy and you're like no I think the
touchstone for that one is the in the
little girl's bedroom the tree at the
end in the train fight is really the one
where you know you're in the middle of
this hopefully this use of a Tony Scott
epic you know train battle and then then
there's that moment where you just go
and pop back and just drops in fact
wasn't one fun thing that we were
thinking about it in pre-production as
as we were thinking about things that
like that the train bite on the train I
remember going into the pantages or
something in Hollywood Boulevard back in
the another Arab 222 ice ages ago to see
like how the west was won and I just
love
of the camera work on that I love the
camera were those exciting westerns and
in and train robbery films and so we
thought well let's invest this little
sequence between these two aunts eyes
characters with all those angles and all
that feeling of fun and energy that we
that we could and then then of course we
just cut to what it really is you know
that one shot and it's speaking of the
train sequence I mean after every
environment that was designed and every
set that was created it was then also
like all right now we have to design the
real set which is the macro set so the
Train the Train the Train table and how
high it was off the ground and where
it's sat in the room and what the was
around and after we disaster that was
designed and we had so many meetings
about it and paste rates of speed of
trains etc etc then became well this is
where it's sitting in the room and then
I had to design the the we have to
design the matte painting for that train
which is the backdrop like what was on
the walls and one of the themes of the
greatest train fights ever kind of came
up when we started doing murals as if
Cassie had drawn cactuses and landscapes
and Arizona and you know just where you
would see these great John Ford epic
films with the best-trained fights ever
now Shepard when you were designing the
film to do you ever go to the actual Ant
Man comics for inspiration yes so
there's always a reference point and and
you almost want to over reference things
and talk about them and how it relates
to the marvel cinematic universe and the
reason to do that is because inevitably
there will be an interest in neutering
that so it's like hey but if you forget
it and don't ever reference it then it's
like why the hell didn't we talk about
this so was definitely like a maybe we
can name at the Kirby hotel hey maybe we
can name this that but one of the key
props that that um that we that we
decided to integrate you know almost you
know as an identical match was in in in
ant-man i forgot what what what what um
what a episode but basically there's a
Kirby had designed
this ant farm and you see it you come
right off of it when you go into the
secure room in pims basement and it's
basically this kind of bullet shaped
thing with a purple top and an ant farm
and answer under than Russell cam came
right off of it to go to Paul and it is
literally it's an identical match and
then and one of the inspirations
obviously this film takes place you know
it takes place over you know a couple of
weeks but it basically takes place over
decades as well because we are showing
the history of him of Hank Pym who he
was in 1989 and before and you needed to
show not just the words of the Pym
particles but the environment in which
it was created in and that was the real
kind of place to show a little bit of
the history which we were able to
integrate you know jack kirby kind of
inspired stuff from Ant Man comics